all right here's the story from the
dailymail.com loaded liberals are paying
millions for golden visas to other
countries because they're scared of a
trump-led civil war in 2024.
i said civil war that means wealthy
wokes planned their escape but why
didn't they go in 2016. now i will say
right off the bat i'm a bit skeptical
but also kind of not like part of me
wants to think it's it's an exaggeration
but part of me kind of believes it we
already saw the story about these
billionaires who are trying to build
bunkers and resorts in new zealand and
stuff and that story's been like going
on for a long time you had the ceo from
reddit who's also one of these woke
wealthy liberals talking about survival
prepping and getting food because they
saw something coming
daily mail says the wealthy wokes are
spending huge sums to bag visas that
allow them to escape to countries like
austria turkey jordan and the caribbean
according to attorneys running the
process consultants say they've seen a
massive spike in interest for
citizenship for second countries all
over the uh countries over the last few
years many americans told them they are
petrified by the thought of another
trump administration
while others cited the roe v wade ruling
in the 2008 crash you know what i love
about that if you want to leave the
united states because you're worried
about abortions yeah go to jordan or
turkey we'll see how that works out if
you want to leave america because you
worried about authoritarianism is is
turkey right the great the the best
runner up is canada yeah this is the
craziest thing i see with this and
people are like i'm gonna move to canada
it's like okay well like they
they were arresting people trying to
leave their homes they called truck
drivers fascists and extremists i mean
we got similar issues going on here in
the u.s but i don't think going to
jordan no you know i don't know
yeah i was just going to say i think
that it's a it's greatly exaggerated i
think that we have to understand that
historically a lot of billionaires and
even multi-millionaires look for areas
to park money that has the best taxation
clauses i mean that's why you have
countries in
uh the caribbean like bermuda things
like this as a two percent uh tax treaty
with america so they park their you know
cash off there you have the uae in dubai
who has a dmz which is a tax-free hub
and
things like this i don't think it has
anything to do i think they're trying to
utilize this as an excuse i think the
real reason they're doing is that
they're looking at the increased
inflation taxation what's going on in
america and the fact that the dollar is
not going as far they probably saw 87
000 new irs agents
exactly maybe i should be a citizen it's
trump's fault
i also love like rich liberals that you
know took a private helicopter from
amman to petra and they're like jordan
is paradise i live in georgia i was like
well yeah that's great it's like you
know you got your tour of the hagia
sophia and you're like i could live in
istanbul sure you could but i i will
just caution and remind everyone that
during president trump's
time in office you actually had more
billionaires and multi-millionaires
moving their cash back onshore to
america and you had businesses returning
to america so i think that
this great exaggeration that they're
fleeing because they're worried about
another trump administration which i'm
certainly hoping for one i think it's
completely far-fetched and they're
running away from the realities because
that doesn't add up to what actually
happened from 16 to 20. peter navarro
was on the show and he was saying well
at least give me that we had the best
economy of our lives or whatever and i i
said no i think that the balloon was
about to burst because of our 24
trillion deficit or uh debt and he was
like oh because he but at the same time
what he was did do well is they were
bringing business back which and it
seemed like it's been a while since
there was a resurgence of american
industry
and they were doing their part right i
mean right now we've got a gdp to
national debt ratio of about 131 percent
so you're talking about an insolvency as
a business owner that means you don't
qualify for a loan that doesn't i mean
that means that you're spending 31 over
what your incoming revenue is so you
know at this stage the only thing that
props up america is the fact that we
have the us dollars being global
currency which is exactly what china
russia and iran is trying to eliminate
is the us dollar from being the global
currency that's the whole point of their
kind of geopolitical alignment they've
been doing that for a long time but now
they're almost close when you talk about
the fact that one they're already
expanding the eurasian border they take
over africa oceania create the maritime
silk route cut off supply chain to the
western hemisphere because we're getting
drug into these endless wars like we're
seeing in ukraine when the reality is is
that this is about economic resource
warfare this isn't about kinetics any
longer you know what's weird about this
article if i could just say if i'm the
the democrat advisor to the biden
campaign world if your wealthy liberals
are already banking on a trump win you
have to be nervous about your campaign
strategy right they're already if
they're already planning to leave then
they don't think he's going to win
perhaps i think a lot of it's probably
that they're saying okay it looks like
trump is going to win so i'm going to
hedge my bets but but i'll be honest too
in in the the source article which comes
from the daily beast they mention
for years david lesperance an
immigration attorney who helps wealthy
americans obtain second citizenships saw
a similar type of client millionaire
maga heads silicon valley libertarians
new money crypto investors basically
rich guys who wanted out of the u.s tax
system
but in recent months he's seen an
increase in a surprising clientele
moneyed liberals who are terrified of
the political future of the country and
want an escape plan
i think after everything we've seen i
mean look they're talking about rolling
blackouts in california perhaps they
should have managed their energy
production better but
these people they
here's what i think
as an aside
they campaign on climate change and then
have no choice but to follow through
with with cutting off their own
electrical grid to appease their own
voters and they're they're spinning
themselves into oblivion now
california's in serious trouble they
couldn't get
they they couldn't build
enough generation to to maintain their
own state despite the fact they've been
screaming about it endlessly now you
have people who are suffering their own
problems leaving places like california
going to arizona or texas and bringing
their problems or their voting patterns
with them but then you have the wealthy
who are looking at all the problems they
created all of the cheering on of the
the the you know going after trump
defense of of of hunter and joe biden
and their illicit business dealings
there's going to be accountability we
saw this in in early 2020 or mid-2020
when the boston globe reported on war
games that were being held by democrats
and you know neocon establishment
republicans
and on the democrat side in the war game
they suggested the west coast secede
from the union if trump were to win
that's where they were in 2020 at least
according to the boston globe
when i hear that they're fleeing now
because they're scared about trump i say
yes and for the moneyed liberals i don't
think it's because they have trump
derangement syndrome i think it's
because these are the people who know
that they've been doing naughty things
and they're going to get caught when
when donald trump or republicans
it's not just any republican it's got to
be republicans who actually take action
actually file subpoenas no i think larry
hogan will go after these guys too and i
can't even finish the comment without
laughing sorry i'll tell you though i i
do think that there's a part of that but
i also think that you're starting to see
a lot more currency hedging as well
where people are actually going and
parking their money offshore they're
exchanging their currency and trading on
the markets and they're you know making
a killing on it basically betting and
shorting the dollar and so um you know i
think a lot of these people they just
have the the amount of money that's
necessary to go ahead and try and
continue to create more wealth and
they're doing it on the backs of
hard-working americans do you think that
they're actually
fleeing's an interesting phrasing but do
you think they're just increasing their
portfolio exactly
and then and finding a way to save money
especially with the the you know it's
funny because that's why i said bermuda
by the way because they literally have a
two percent tax treaty and there's
things that people will go and buy like
insurance captives
and then they will do something in one
of their businesses they will file an
insurance claim against it pay
themselves out insurance claims aren't
taxed and then they're basically just
circumventing the system so you know
this is where the idea of needing eighty
seven thousand deep state police added
into our system with the six hundred
thousand dollars in small calorie
ammunition isn't the fix it's actually
fixing the loopholes and making sure
that we hold those accountable who are
actually trying to do these things i
think the the the money liberal types
and look the democratic party's become
the party of the wealthy vox.com said
this not fox vox vox
said in 2016 the democrats had become
the party of the wealthy they've they've
been coming they've become whiter
and wealthier over the past several
elections which is which is funny and
the republican party is becoming more
diverse and more working class
so of course
these are people who are like
well with joe biden making these moves
to raise taxes and stuff i got to do
what i got to do you know and what i see
with joe biden's move in the democrats
move with the irs for instance they're
not going to go after the rich people no
because the rich people fight back if
you if if the irs sends a bill to a
millionaire and says you owe us axe
he'll be alike you know he'll give him
the call to his law firm and say hey
handle this for me and rebecca you got
it and the irs got to deal with it and
they're like we're going to lose money
in man hours
send the bill for 500 bucks to that
working class joe who can't afford to
fight back that's right do that to 10
000 working-class joes and we're gonna
make a pretty penny yeah and you will
you'll just you'll just pay the fine
because you can't afford the attorneys
and we were just saying before we went
live you know this is this was the
strategy of mayor bowser in in
washington dc as the city was struggling
for revenue she hired
thousands more more meter maids we used
to call them and you know you show up to
your car you're totally within your
limits you've obeyed all the signs all
the parking rules you paid but you have
a 35 ticket 50 ticket and what are you
gonna do you're gonna take a day off of
work to go stand before a judge for
fifty dollars no you curse you scream
you pay the fifty dollars and she knows
that's what you're gonna do she doesn't
care about truth or justice and that's
what these irs agents are going to do
maybe not you know 50 but honestly if i
got a 500 irs fine
i can't that's my lawyer's fees would be
more than that exactly you're going to
curse you're going to scream and you'll
be like damn it and here's the 500 i
remember one time i got two tickets in
the mail that were uh final notice 150 i
think was due two of them 300 bucks and
this was back when i was making like 10
bucks an hour working at the airport in
chicago and i was like what did i get
tickets for
looked him up and it said i had
illegally parked in chicago months ago
never got a ticket on my car nope never
parked illegally and when i called them
and said this must be a mistake they
said well you didn't respond to the
first two so now it's too late you have
to pay it's a final determination and i
said i never got a ticket doesn't matter
prove to me you didn't get it yep
exactly that's very common prove that
you didn't get it i think that's that's
fascinating uh that's metaphysically
well but this is the way it works right
it's it's guilty until proven innocent
not innocent until proven guilty the way
it was originally set yeah and it shows
you you just mentioned the california
thing um
it shows you what i think a lot of
government and government bureaucrats
what they really think of their
constituents right
yeah exactly you know we don't care
about what this is bad for you if this
isn't inconvenient if this is illegal
unconstitutional we don't care that tim
didn't do this we just need his damn
money but i'll tell you this is why you
know when i talk to my my you know more
moderate liberal types friends and they
tell me they're in favor of defunding
the police this is exactly why yeah so i
i was talking to a friend of mine who
lives in like a well-off suburban area
and i was like why would you want to
defund the police you live in the
suburbs that's where the cops are good
and she said it's because we all keep
getting pulled over and we don't do
anything wrong and they tell us to go to
court over it and we can't and we're all
like everyone's been talking about we're
pissed and then i was like
well i get it i completely get it if if
you're seeing something in your
community like quota systems or
something then you're gonna be like
don't know don't care but i tell you
this the funny repercussion of that is
going to be you may be upset they're
milking money out of you but you get rid
of the police and then see what happens
yeah well that's what we're seeing right
now which is increased criminality i
mean that's exactly what's going on
lawlessness and then you have the
democrats solved on crime policies you
have these catch and release policies
these nobel policies and you're seeing
an increase and now people are
terrorized to go out in areas that are
democrat controlled like seattle and new
york etc thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there